the awards are coming the awards are
coming in coming to present the next one
is a gracious and talented lady who's
always been a reigning member of royalty
in the celluloid cart it's of course
herself Miss Irene Dunne
the Academy's Board of Governors at its
discretion votes the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award to that member of the
motion picture family whose humanitarian
efforts have brought credit to our
industry such a man is Georges Bank now
we for 35 years has devoted his keen
mind his boundless energy and his great
warm heart to helping us all through the
motion picture Relief Fund and the
permanent charities campaigns I speak
for a grateful community in thanking mr.
Bergner for his unselfish devotion to
humanity and I honor him with the
presentation of the Jean Hersholt award
while Jean Hersholt was a friend of mine
and he's a friend of all mankind has the
former president of the motion picture
Relief Fund
he left footprints that were deep enough
to withstand the erosions of time and
wings I'm gratified you think I've been
able to follow it and I thank you
sincerely for this treasured honor but
thank you even more for your continued
support of our industry-sponsored
welfare agencies I have to add that I
again thank the Academy and the industry
with which I have been identified thank
you very much